[Music]
27:42 requesting release i here to
harvest I have the location of a massive
deposit of aurillac the Queen's lair
about my estimation is the largest
anyone's ever seen
[Music]
someone is approaching what are you from
nowhere how poetic
the Queen's lair
where's target
well it's something I have never seen
and all my time in the green little girl
[Applause]
we're in the same trough you and I you
don't have a ship no I don't but you
will find a way to get on if you find
that buried cuz yeah why should I trust
you you're a killer
I am indeed what are you how can offer
protection I same together we ravage the
Queens lair even spite of course I
sustained a weed I was hoping you had
some juice
here is our offer I don't understand for
the girl that is a bold offer
[Music]
- trust me you're trying to trick me
here's all in the name of
self-preservation birdie it was nothing
personal
[Music]
lorelei prospectin he's indeed an
obscure craft an odd for him were they
have the highest orders of you some of
us have the proclivity for greatness
almost do you know it was ambitious
masses but the sacrifice this forest
demands so that the true divine us can
stand atop the mountain of corpses who
claim their riches
which one of you
[Music]
you